je m'appelle églantine victorine j'ai 49
ans j'habite à saint-gilles-les-hauts
dans le dix neuvième canton je suis
conseillère départementale du dix
neuvième canton qui parle de ravine
daniel à la saline les bains dans la
commune de saint paul
je suis très attaché à ce canton parce
que j'y ai grandi
ça fait plus de vingt ans que je milite
dans ce secteur je connais bien la
population les associations je peux dire
que je suis chez moi
je suis une élue de proximité et je vais
m'engager dans le social mes priorités
sont
apportés les services au plus près des
personnes âgées et handicapées
l'insertion des jeunes et l'amélioration
de l'habitat
j'ai choisi le département comme ti la
signature le département au plus près
des réunionnais et moi je serai proche
de la population je rends compte les
personnes que ce soit les jeunes les
personnes âgées personnes handicapées
des associations les agriculteurs me
font part de leurs difficultés et avec
le département on pourra les accompagner